hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my face book readers well
dear Grodin asking about how to create a
personal objective statement so he wrote
insane
hi Evan I've started my work as an
assistant account in an oral exploration
company I have to write my personal
objectives and personal goal that may be
beneficial to the company the problem is
I'm stuck I don't know where to start
and I'm asking for some hints on how it
can start so thanks for the question
bill dear I think there are most of the
time I'm helping entrepreneurs but in
your situation I think that the question
it can also relate to entrepreneurs for
you what I start thinking about is why
are you an accountant or why are you
interested in the oil industry
right what gets you really excited about
this hopefully it's not just about the
money
there's got to be something beyond that
that drives it maybe you really love
numbers you love helping people you love
the excitement of the oil industry
whatever it is I start to tap into that
passion because that will help guide
your career as you go forward because
you know what you're really excited
about and what you want to hopefully
accomplish with your career and you can
take a job path or an entrepreneurial
path that gets you closer to - you know
what you're really excited about so too
many people wake up and they go to a job
that they hate right that's that's most
of the world you know the wake up and
they go to a job that they hate so as
entrepreneurs we have the chance to make
our own job and create our own destiny
but also as an employee you have the
chance to you know work towards a career
path that is more exciting for you and
that starts with really understanding
what you're excited about
but if you don't have a personal goal or
you don't really know what excites you
then then it's hard right you're not
probably gonna have really exciting
passionate fulfilled life so you want to
start around that like why don't you
become interesting accounting or why do
you want to apply at an oil company
versus another type of company what is
what drew you to that opportunity and
hopefully something more than money is
something that you can really tap into a
deep passion of yours of helping people
are learning a specific skill set or
you're learning more about an industry
so that's where I would start
forget about the business that you're at
for the moment just think about yourself
because this this is a long-term thing
for you right you're gonna you're gonna
have the rest of your life to work
towards accomplishing you know what's on
this paper so you want your your
personal goals to tap into the deep
passion of yours and then you think
about the business that you're at now
you know this could be a long-term
forever opportunity or it could be
something that's shorter term and having
your you know your passion clearly laid
out will help you figure that out but
then once you know what you're really
strongly passionate about you can think
about okay well how can I apply this at
the company that I'm currently at and
maybe there's a really strong fit maybe
you know this company can solve all my
needs and and I'm gonna be happy here
for us in my life or maybe the company
can only help me in certain areas of
things that I want to accomplish with my
career and if if that's the case and
that's great it may be a short term you
know a couple years placement for you
but just write down two things that you
hope to gain from this company and
you're gonna help them with some things
and they're gonna help you as well
so hopefully that helps you I think it's
great for entrepreneurs to go through
the exercise to what do you want to
accomplish as an entrepreneur you know
what what do you mean what do you hope
to grow and learn and hopefully it's
more than just I want to make a lot of
money the only one have an impact you
want to do something you're really you
know passionate about if it's being
creative or programming or whatever it
is you want to be doing work where
you're learning growing and helping
people and coming up with your own
personal you know objective statement
can be helped really beneficial to help
guide your career or your business so
hopefully that helped if you guys liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below
I love seeing those come in that makes
you want to create more of these videos
for you guys
and if you have a question or you want
to leave a comment you have something to
say about this video I'd love to hear it
if you want to become an underneath the
video so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode
you